معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام
اهلا بك ابرز التطورات التي حملتها
الساعات الماضيه في
غزه هو استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي في اكثر
من محافظه واكثر من منطقه لا سما المنطقه
الوسطى وخانيونس يتركز القصف هذه الايام
وخلال الساعات الماضيه في هذه المناطق
المناطق الشرقيه الجنوبيه لخان يونسي التي
تتعرض الى القصف الاعنف القصف الاكثر حده
الغارات الاسرائيليه لا تتوقف على تلك
المناطق ولا لحظه واحده ايضا القصف
المدفعي مستمر ويسمع صداح حتى في اقصى
مدينه رفع هنا في جنوب قطاع غزه حيث
نتواجد هنا نسمع اصوات انفجارات مختلفه
وعنيفه من جراء القصف الاسرائيلي المستمر
على مدينه خانيونس ولا سما المنطقه
الفاصله ما بين خانيونس ورفع هذه المنطقه
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه وكذلك من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه الطائرات
الحربيه شنت سلسله من الغارات لم تعرف
طبيعتها لان طواقم الدفاع المدني وطواقم
الاسعاف لا تستطيع الوصول الى تلك الاماكن
لا سما في ظل توغل الجيش الاسرائيلي في
تلك المناطق في المناطق الشرقيه وشرق
مدينه خانيونس بالتالي هو قصف اسرائيلي
مستمر وهذا القصف مستمر في ظل انقطاع
للاتصالات للانترنت بسبب عمليات التجريف
التي قامت بها الدبابات الاسرائيليه
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه على مدار
اربعه ايام لا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف
وسيارات الدفاع المدني الوصول الى المناطق
مقصوفه بسبب عدم تمكنها من التواصل مع
بعضها البعض بسبب عدم
تمكن المواطنين الفلسطينيين من التواصل مع
غرف الطوارئ سواء التابعه للاسعاف او تلك
التابعه لطواقم الدفاع المدني ايضا حتى
سيارات شركه الاتصالات الفلسطينيه تتعرض
للاستهداف بالامس تعرضت سياره تابعه لشركه
الاتصالات وكانت تعمل على صيانه الخطوط
التي قطعتها الدبابات والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه استشهد اثنان من موظفي شركه
الاتصالات الفلسطين ينيه في خانيونس جراء
قصفهم من طائره مسيره اسرائيليه كانوا
يحاولون عمل صيانه لهذه الخطوط الفلسطينيه
المقطوعه من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالتالي هي عمليه قصف اسرائيلي مستمره
ايضا في دير البلح وسط القطاع قصفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه منزلين على
الاقل من الطائرات الحربيه وبالتالي هناك
قصف هناك عدد من الشهداء نقلوا الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى لكن حتى عمليات القصف
وعمليات نقل الشهداء هي عمليات متاخره
بسبب عدم قدره السكان على التواصل مع
طواقم الاسعاف وبالتالي هم يذهبون ويجل
بعض الشهداء من قبل سيارات مدنيه او حتى
عربات تجرها الحيوانات الى المستشفى ومن
ثم تقوم السيارات الاسعاف بعد معرفتها
بهذه الاماكن بالتوجه الى مناطق القصف
الاسرائيلي قصفت الطائرات منزلين سواتهما
بالارض احدهما في منطقه البركه في دير
البلح والاخر في منطقه البصه وهناك عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى ايضا المناطق الشرقيه
لدير البلح تتعرض ض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات وكذلك من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
ايضا مخيم المغازي يتعرض ربما الى القصف
الاعنف القصف الاكثر حده قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه عده منازل في هذا
المخيم الصغير
والمكتظة في مخيم المغازي
وهؤلاء نسف المنزل في مخيم المغازي على
رؤوس السكان الذين كانوا يتواجدون فيه
بالتالي اعداد الشهداء ترتفع يوما بعد اخر
من جراء عمليات القصف المستمره لكن حتى
عمليات القصف وعمليات التدمير وعمليات
القصف المدفعي لا تستطيع طواقم الدفاع
المدني الوصول الى تلك المناطق التي
تقصفها المدفعيه او الطائرات بسبب تواجد
الدبابات الاسرائيليه على شارع صلاح الدين
مقابل مخيم المغازي كذلك مقابل مخيم
البريج وهي تقصف كل من يحاول التحرك
بالاضافه الى ان هناك طائرات كواد كابتر
اسرائيليه تطلق النار على كل من يتحرك
ويحا ويحاول الانتقال من من شرق شارع صلاح
الدين الى غربه او بالعكس وبالتالي
الانتقال من دير البلح الى مخيم المغازي
هي مهمه صعبه او حتى تحرك سيارات الاسعاف
بسبب هذه الطائرات الكواد كابتر التي تطلق
النار او حتى الطائرات المسيره التي تقصف
كما قصفت سياره تابعه للهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني قبل عده ايام ايضا مخيم البريج
يتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه والقصف ربما الاكثر خطوره
والاكثر عنفا هو في مخيم النصيرات لا سما
في المناطق الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات كذلك
المناطق الشرقيه للمخيم ما بين شارع
العشرين وشارع صلاح الدين تتعرض الى قصف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وهناك ايضا
طائرات كواد كابتر تحلق في سماء تلك
المنطقه وتطلق النار على المواطنين في تلك
المناطق هذا بخصوص المناطق في وسط وجنوب
القطاع ايضا في مناطق الشمال ومناطق مدينه
غزه هناك غارات متفرقه ما بين الفينه
والاخرى وعلى ما يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يكثف من غاراته خلال اليومين الماضيين
شهدنا عده غارات في حي الزيتون في حي
الصبره في حي الدرج وكل هذه الغارات كانت
تستهدف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وعندما نتحدث
عن مدينه غزه وعن شمال القطاع نحن نتحدث
عن احياء بكاملها دمرت والمنازل القائمه
هي منازل قليله للغايه وبالتالي مكتظه
بالسكان لان السكان تلجا الى بعضها البعض
المنازل القائمه هي يتواجد فيها عشرات من
العائلات الفلسطينيه مئات من الافراد
وبالتالي اي غاره اسرائيليه على اي من
المنازل في مدينه غزه او في شمال القطاع
فنحن نتحدث عن عشرات من الشهداء في ظل نقص
في المعدات في ظل نقص في المستلزمات
وبالتالي هناك شهداء واعداد كبيره من
هؤلاء الشهداء جراء استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي في كافه المناطق شكرا لك هشام
زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من رفح